but we're going to start with this big
story that everybody's talking about
because we're beginning at a pivotal
moment for minneapolis and the country
really
with closing arguments all set today in
the trial of former police officer derek
shovin
it's less than a year after we first saw
him kneeling on george floyd's
neck those who have kept a shrine
deployed near where he was killed and
have marched and demanded justice are
all watching very very closely this
moment also comes amid
new protests nationwide over two other
deaths involving the police
jamie yukis is outside the courthouse in
minneapolis which has been transformed
by very heavy security jamie what's the
mood there
well anthony i can tell you tensions are
high the minnesota governor tim walls is
calling for calm
after 45 witnesses and hours of
testimony and cross-examination
minneapolis and state leaders are
bracing for unrest
national guard troops are deployed
throughout minneapolis working alongside
state and city police officers
the governor has requested more law
enforcement
from neighboring states minneapolis
public schools officials
are also bracing for the verdict
switching students to remote learning
later this week for their safety
after they hear closing arguments jamie
what are the next steps for the jurors
in this case
anthony i can tell you the judge will
read them instructions drawn up by the
court
with input from both the prosecution and
the defense
14 jurors sat through the trial hearing
testimony from witnesses
the judge will have to dismiss the two
alternate jurors
and then the remaining jurors will pick
a foreperson
who will monitor the deliberations and
take the verdict into court
they will be sequestered while they
review the evidence that means
no contact with the outside world as
they make this very important decision
they will need to come to decisions on
the three-count chauvin is facing
that is second degree unintentional
murder third degree murder
and second degree manslaughter the
jury's decision
guilty or not has to be unanimous
anthony
jamie yucas in minneapolis thank you
jamie